this this printing of money is nuts the
federal debt to gdp is 128.6
how insane is that but there's one thing
that's going to break the camel's back
george clooney calls for movie theaters
to receive
federal bailout amid pandemic george
clooney calls for movie theaters to
receive
federal bailout money well he's an actor
so no but these are movie theaters
dude okay there's a difference between
it's a dead art form
movie theaters yeah no hell wants to pay
a bunch of money to go sit in the
building to watch something you could
you could spin up on netflix now i got a
giant monitor in your house
i love movie theaters what does it look
like it's a 50 60 foot screen
is nostalgia but it's it's a function so
expensive to run
yeah and they're in new jersey they're
being all shut down so
i uh this segue the point is i think
it's interesting to see
what what i think is really happening
with george clooney calling for federal
bailout money
you know you know where that money goes
for movie theaters it gets paid to the
movie industry yeah he's talking about
giving himself
a paycheck without saying give me a
paycheck
these these hoity-toity say whatever
celebrities
love espousing all of the democrat
messages and now
the people they support have destroyed
the economy and in new jersey where amc
is like suing i guess and completely
destroyed
he's like oh you got to build the movie
theaters and give him them some money
yeah yeah yeah and then
and then you know when the movies can
come back let's talk about nazism for a
minute because that's
national socialism and he's trying to
use socialism to fund these businesses
it sounds like violence
it sounds like world war ii germany all
these people talking about using
more government money that's been
overused yeah
let's talk about national socialism what
do you want to use american money for
again guys
that's socialism hollywood actors
are the people who have pushed us into
this mess not not entirely on their own
but they've been supporting lunatics
like newsom and
and these and these these people like
cuomo defending them doing psas as
and at the same time as they tell you to
protest black lives matter in cringy
little videos where they
self-righteously tell you
about how we need to apologize so let's
let's let's play two ways
let's say they have all these massive
protests from black lives matter and
then we get a coveted pandemic okay
that's your fault you're the one telling
people to go outside
then the people they've supported
politically destroy all these businesses
and then he goes just print us some
money why don't you
just just print us some money huh how
about that yeah you know what man
these people are something else i guess
the nazis didn't have crypto
i mean like we we need to look at this
like pre-world war two germany
because we're in a situation where if a
strong man came in trump if he had gone
psycho probably could have done a hitler
thing but he didn't
well we're talking about hollywood yes
so what do you think about george
clooney uh
very kind of plus i mean i i pulled up
the article here and it's
absolutely just flabbergasted to see so
many
low information idiots out there always
thinking that we could just print more
money and then
everything is solved everything just
magically comes back it's about they're
doing it for themselves about them
what else is their entire career about
what else is their entire virtual
signaling about what else is their
entire kind of life about other than
give me enough money and i'll read the
scripts and i'll do it and i'll perform
it in a better way than anyone else in
the face of the world
that's exactly what actually is but
these people are advertisements yeah
that's what they've always been
and so when it comes to the democrats
they've always
gone to these personalities and these
celebrities to use them to to to
you know essentially gain power to
manipulate and it's marketing i want to
make it seem like it's all that
nefarious
they find people that are popular they
pay them to say the message
these people get elected and now that
these people are saying oh no our
industry has gone belly up well that's
what you supported
exactly and so there's enough money
they'll do anything
for that money and it's kind of sad when
you look at hollywood it's it's truly an
industry that is extremely seedy
extremely disgusting
that you see so many horror stories come
out of and when you look at a lot of
these celebrities i mean we even saw you
know dr fauci i think he's kind of
considered a celebrity he came out today
and he said
you know people shouldn't really spend
christmas with their family members
together
gretchen whitmore the governor of
michigan released on a
horrible video with her and santa and
children
with santa telling the little kids
remember
listen to the governor and whitmer
saying you know it's best if you don't
spend christmas with your family members
but hold on let me just make a little
point here because i think it's
important to understand here that these
same individuals are abusing this entire
situation for their own personal gain
and if and if let's say there was an
actual real threat say there actually
was a
big huge serious illness sickness going
around if they were taking it seriously
and
and they were saying hey maybe we
shouldn't protest hey maybe we shouldn't
uh have you know best buy open for black
friday
everyone lined up outside maybe we
shouldn't be celebrating a presidential
victory and drinking booze and sharing
it with everyone
maybe if they were taking it seriously
themselves maybe i would
but i will never be lectured by these
fat cat plutocrats who don't listen to
their own orders
telling me what to do i'm sorry they
don't take it seriously i'm not going to
take it seriously either and it's
disgusting to see them
and this larger establishment always
push out these dumb ideas
that bring down our national iq to this
insane level
where right now we literally have santa
claus being used and abused
to make sure that little children are
low and worship a governor it's an
extraction
it's an extraction these people don't
think about the better future for
everybody
these people aren't the ones saying a
rising tide raises all or
raises all ships what they're saying is
there's only so much water in this bay i
better take it for myself not realizing
what are you gonna do
what are you gonna do so when we see
people like clooney in hollywood he's
like well
one of the what he's basically saying is
we're one of the biggest exporters so we
must be subsidized
bro printing money and giving it to you
won't produce product to send over the
world
that's a bs excuse you're an ultra
wealthy individual mad your industry is
in trouble just like everybody else's
but you think they should bail you out
well maybe you shouldn't support the
people who shut down your industry
and that's what you did and at the same
time these democrat governors who got
the support from these celebrities
are the ones who are basically saying
how much can i extract from the working
class before the system goes belly up
that's what we see with gretchen whitmer
she's burning it all down
and as it all crumbles she's looting the
she's looting the burning homes of the
of the towns
and then george clooney and all these
other celebrities are seeing this as a
massive opportunity saying give me some
give me some of the the money before you
all goes bust exactly
yeah but come on remember the panama
papers how many of these celebrities
popped up in this having money overseas
yep a whole lot
i can't remember i can't remember who it
was but there was some woman and i
i can't remember exactly it was some
female celebrity and she was like i had
no idea
oh it's just my advisors were putting my
money in panama
and then wasn't it the person who leaked
like the like one of the journalists
covering the panama papers turned up
dead
yes there was um yeah that that
did happen i don't know the exact uh
parameters behind
that but the story hasn't been covered
as widely as it should
uh but just disappeared one day yep well
i think it was
more of a blatant kind of attack and
assassination
i would have to look into it more to
give you more exact details but i
remember hearing
a lot about that but i think the mexican
president pretty much
accurately depicts what's going on he
recently came out and he said
the lockdowns are just the form of
dictatorship
so he's not locking down mexico life in
mexico is a lot different than it is in
the united states and who would have
ever thought
that you know mexico is is doing a lot
better
than the united states how much want to
bet the peso is going to start going up
well depends on the peso is also very
very closely tied into the us dollar
a lot of foreign currencies are tied
into the u.s dollar so if we see the
dollar go we're going to see the whole
world currency
be affected by it very severely as the
us dollar is the world reserve
see listen listen this is the benefit of
the military industrial complex in the
petro dollar
this is the benefit of the us saying
we'll blow you up if you don't agree to
our dollar
like you know qaddafi or saddam hussein
right exactly and
and again we have to understand here
with these extreme times governments
are just using this as an opportunity
the ship
is sinking they're trying to take as
much as they can as it goes down
and i think that's really exemplified
there was a recent report
that studied the lockdowns and the kovid
responses from governments and
they ruled that freedom is the biggest
casualty of covet 19
not just they were in the united well
states think it also
determined determined ruled found out
included
concluded whatever word you want to use
here but this was a pretty stunning
report
by an international group that looked
into all the government's responses from
africa to asia and they outlined how you
know in nigeria there was massive
crackdowns on protest
uh and you know the restrictions were
set in place to make sure that there
wasn't anyone challenging the political
status quo there in bolivia they
postponed
the general elections in sri lanka the
government accelerated its authoritarian
agenda stepping up efforts to control
independent reporting and quote
unfavorable speech
by ordering the arrest of anyone who
criticized the government
and we're seeing this not just done in
democratically heavy
states and cities in the united states
but we're seeing this done
all over the world using this pandemic
using covet 19 as an excuse
to ravage our civil liberties to ravage
our freedoms and to take whatever they
want for themselves and it's working and
they're getting away it is working for
an
alan voting thing was another example of
that
changing the 20 rand paul said two dozen
states changed their election rules
without approval from the state
legislatures
yeah two dozen cuomo is banning symbols
he doesn't like
i'm concerned that this will be used as
a premise to war
i told my friend that we were talking
about uh trump's drone
strikes and i was like well what if my
fear is that the drones get hacked and
then
they're flown back over or lebron did
that yeah or that there's like an
unknown assailant from orbit that
torches a bunch of u.s cities and we
don't know who did it
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you